[Musique]
lorsque vous pensez à la politique vous
vient probablement l'esprit des images
de grands débats de déclarations chocs
ou encore de contestataires qui
manifestent
il est peu probable que vous viennent à
l'esprit des images de consultation
publique de rapports gouvernementaux ou
encore de réunions d'experts dans une
salle sans décorum la politique que l'on
vous montre est une politique qui
divertissent on ne vous montre pas la
politique qui fonctionne pourquoi en
tant qu expert en politiques publiques
c'est une question que je me pose depuis
plus de 20 ans je suis convaincu que la
politique fonctionne mieux que nous le
croyons et que notre cynisme à son égard
est exagéré mais nous ne pouvons pas
compter sur les médias pour nous le
faire comprendre
il ya presque exactement 28 ans j'étais
arrivé derrière l'écran de mon
téléviseur comme des millions
téléspectateurs partout à travers le
monde a regardé des images comme celles
ci montrent à un début d'une guerre la
première guerre du golfe
grâce aux nouvelles en continu qui en
était alors alors tout premiers
balbutiements
nous pouvions voir en direct le
déroulement de seigneur or les nouvelles
ont alors pris une tournure captivante
après la guerre pour garder leurs cotes
d écoute pour garder votre attention
les médias se sont tournés vers ce qu'il
y a de plus spectaculaire en politique
vers des controverses
les conflits policiers been illustrée
par les premières images que je vous ai
montré aujourd'hui les médias sont
contraints de vous montrer une politique
qui divertit les nouvelles en continu
ont transformé la dynamique médiatique
et les médias sociaux n'ont fait
qu'accentuer le phénomène
les policiers qui ont besoin d'être vus
et les autres acteurs politiques aussi
se sont ajustés à ce nouveau contexte
politique pour être vu ils n'hésitent
pas à crier leur indignation
et parfois il crie très fort se donne en
spectacle
si plutôt que de vous montrer dans notre
chambre
on vous montrait des images d'une
discussion rationnelle sur un sujet
sérieux de politiques publiques la
réglementation du transport maritime par
exemple une discussion au comité un peu
comme celle que nous voyons à l'écran
vous iriez vite voir ailleurs la
politique qui fonctionne est moins
divertissante et l'intéressent - le
public
à quand remonte la dernière fois que
vous avez visité le site web d'un
ministère pour vous informer sur une
politique publique la politique une
salaire minimum par exemple ou celle
elle se rend la salubrité de la
nourriture des informations de ce type
sont faciles à trouver
depuis l'avènement d'internet les
gouvernements se sont obligés eux mêmes
rendre publique une foule d'informations
sur ce qu'ils font aujourd'hui les
démocraties occidentales sont plus
transparents qu'elles ne l'ont jamais
été mais je suppose que vous êtes comme
moi le soir en rentrant à la maison
après une longue journée de travail
vous n'avez pas le goût de lire le
dernier rapport du ministère du travail
sur le seuil au delà duquel le salaire
minimum nuit à l'économie ou encore
celui du ministère de la santé sur la
contamination microbienne dans les
abattoirs de volailles
nous préférons un contenu plus diverses
a d'ailleurs il ya quelques temps je
participais une émission de télé avec
des journalistes durant laquelle je
déplorais une couverture médiatique trop
négative la politique les journalistes
présents ne sont pas prier pour me
rappeler que dès qu'ils montrent des
nouvelles positives
les gens changent de poste il ya donc un
piège dont il est difficile de sortir
on vous montre la politique qui divertit
parce que s'ils ont vraiment la
politique qui fonctionne
vous allez voir ailleurs les conflits
politiques qui vous divertissent
alimente aussi votre cynisme ils minent
votre confiance envers le système
politique
alors votre attitude face à la politique
devient toujours plus négative lorsque
l'on demande aux canadiens
quelle profession il voit positivement
ils sont seulement 24% a mentionné la
politique
à l'opposé c'est 89% de la population
canadienne qui mentionne les
scientifiques et ses résultats ne sont
pas propres au canada des résultats
semblables ont été obtenues vous êtes
unis en europe
un tel cynisme face à la politique est
dangereux il met la table pour des
politiciens qui comme dans notre chambre
souhaite détruire le système
il se serait dommage c'est y arriver car
la politique à améliorer nos vies de
façon considérable depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale et elle continue
de le faire comment
en fonctionnant un peu comme la science
qui de toute évidence nous inspire
confiance
les scientifiques sont souvent partie
prenante de la politique qui fonctionne
on ne met pas en place des normes
sanitaires dans les abattoirs
sans parler des microbiologistes pas
plus que l'on fixe le seuil du salaire
minimum sans parler des économistes il
faut aussi savoir que les scientifiques
participent à la politique qui
fonctionne proviennent souvent des
universités ils jouissent donc d'une
grande indépendance est peut-être un peu
à cause de cette indépendance leurs
propos ne conviennent pas toujours aux
politiciens
en effet ni scientifiques souhaitent que
leurs connaissances servent à améliorer
les politiques pas à divertir un public
friand de conflit il n'aime pas
participé au spectacle
lorsque les politiciens et les médias
s'intéressent un peu trop à eux ils
retournent rapidement vers la
tranquillité de leurs laboratoires ils
délaissent toute implication dans le
monde politique en 2012 je participais à
un colloque à boulder au colorado qui
réunissait des grands chercheurs sur les
changements climatiques dont certains
qui figure parmi les premiers à nous
avons fait comprendre la gravité de ce
problème
après avoir entendu quelques
présentations
j'ai eu un doute me demandant si je
n'existais pas plutôt un colloque de
climato sceptiques les connaissances que
je croyais pourtant solide était
sérieusement remise en question toutes
passées les façon d'estimer la
température du passé les méthodes pour
mesurer la température actuelle et la
validité des simulations qui servent à
prédire les changements à venir
évidemment aucune caméra dans la salle
j'ai bien vite compris que je n'existais
pas un colloque du team et aux
sceptiques
qu'est ce que je voyais n'était rien
d'autre que la méthode scientifique à
l'heure
la science fait progresser les
connaissances en les remettant
constamment en question et y
scientifiques construisent leur
crédibilité
en adoptant cette attitude imaginez
maintenant un politicien que vous auriez
élu parce que vous aimez sa position sur
les changements climatiques
imaginez là en train d'émettre un doute
non pas sur l'existence ou non des
changements climatiques mais sur la
pertinence d'une taxe carbone pour
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre faut savoir qu'il existe d'autres
politiques qui permettent d'atteindre
cet objectif est que la taxe carbone
n'est pas assurément supérieur à ses
autres politiques le doute serait donc
légitime mais dans le contexte la
politique qui divertit votre politiciens
se ferait rapidement cloué au pilori par
ses adversaires
il dirait de lui qu'il manque de
conviction qu'ils cèdent facilement la
pression qu'il est un faible effet ça
ces critiques
peut-être que vous même aurier
l'impression d'avoir été trahis par
votre policiers celui ci n'aurait fait
que je comporter comme un scientifique
qui questionne ses connaissances pour
les améliorer voilà sans doute pourquoi
les scientifiques se sauve en courant
lorsque l'on attend d'eux qu'ils
participent à la politique qui divertit
la politique qui divertit est une
politique de conflit ces participants
doivent tenir des propos exagérés sur
leurs adversaires avec une confiance
absolue
les critiques les attaques portent
davantage sur les adversaires que sur
les arguments
le doute n'est pas permis le doute est
associée à la faiblesse quiconque
douterait se ferait immédiatement traité
de girouette
à l'opposé la science est un monde
prudence de nuances de questionnements
de doutes et parfois de changement
d'opinion encore une fois et
scientifique améliorent leurs
connaissances en les questionnant
constamment des scientifiques sont
souvent à l'aise avec la politique qui
fonctionne parce que celle ci a beaucoup
en commun avec la science la politique
fonctionne est ouverte à la diversité
des points de vue et les modérés et les
centres et sur les arguments et elle
permet à chacun de doutes et de ses
opinions
maintenant il faudrait éviter de trop
proposer la politique qui divertit est
la politique qui fonctionne si
globalement la politique fonctionne
c'est que des personnes qui participent
à la politique qui divertit sont aussi
capables de contribuer à la politique
qui fonctionne pendant plus de dix ans
mes recherches ont porté sur la
politique sur les organismes
génétiquement modifiés les ogm en
amérique du nord et en europe un jour de
passage à bruxelles
je vois un reportage dans un journal sur
l'une des fameuses opération anti ogm
organisée par greenpeace
un peu comme celle que nous voyons à
l'écran dans le reportage
un représentant de l'industrie
réagissait à l'opération avec beaucoup
d'indignation
il affirmait que greenpeace au fond
n'avait qu'un seul objectif non pas la
protection de l'environnement
mais la faillite de l'industrie quelques
jours plus tard je croisais ce même
représentant de l'industrie à une
rencontre organisée par la commission
européenne sur son règlement concernant
la traçabilité des semences ogm en plus
de représentants de l'industrie avait à
la réunion des scientifiques des
représentants de consommateurs de
groupes d'agriculteurs et des
environnementalistes dont greenpeace
lors de la rencontre
personne l'accusé personnes de quoi que
ce soit les échanges étaient centrées
sur les arguments des uns et des autres
tous travailler à l'amélioration du
règlement pas étonnant que la rencontre
et permis d'améliorer le règlement est à
mes yeux du moins à renforcer la
crédibilité des parties prenantes des
rencontres de ce type ont lieu
quotidiennement dans les capitales des
démocraties occidentales et elles
améliorent nos vies
la nourriture que nous consommons et
plus sécuritaire que jamais comme le
sont nos moyens de transport et nos
milieux de travail à plusieurs endroits
la criminalité diminue de façon
constante depuis des années nous
préservons mieux notre patrimoine et
disposant de davantage d'espacé vert
protégé qu'auparavant la qualité de
l'air dans nos villes est meilleure et
l'accès aux soins de santé bien qu est
parfait n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'il
était il ya 50 ans notre espérance de
vie n'a jamais été aussi longue
malheureusement nous nous rendons trop
rarement compte que ces progrès sont
attribuables aux politiques publiques
parce que la politique que l'on nous
montre est une politique qui divertit
cette politique accroît aussi indûment
notre cynisme
comment sortir du piège en étant bien
conscient que la politique ne se résume
pas à ce que nous voyons dans les médias
la politique ce n'est pas que les
policiers que nous connaissons c'est
aussi des rencontres de personnes que
vous ne connaissez pas le soir après une
longue journée de travail
vous pouvez continuer à regarder à la
télé les politiciens qui se crêpent le
chignon
plutôt que de dire un rapport
gouvernemental sur une politique
publique et chicken de politiciens sont
bien plus divers
centre moi aussi c'est ce que je préfère
regarder mais sachez qu'à côté de cela
existe une politique moins visibles
beaucoup moins glamour mais combien plus
importante
une politique qui engagent des personnes
qui cherchent pas forcément la notoriété
mais qui possèdent des expériences des
expertises et des connaissances utiles
aux politiques publiques des personnes
capables de douter et de revoir leur
opinion lorsque les arguments des autres
le justifie et cette politique
fonctionne
elles améliorent nos vies comme la
science la politique mérite notre
confiance nous devrions être moins
cynique
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]